on l'a vu récemment on trouve au québec
de plus en plus de pesticides dans nos
rivières
une situation qui préoccupe la
population en général mais aussi bien
des agriculteurs pour diminuer
l'utilisation qu'ils font de ces
substances plusieurs producteurs
prennent part projet pilote et vous
allez le voir il déploie beaucoup
d'efforts qui donne des résultats
[Musique]
néonicotinoïdes glyphosate atrazine la
chimie agricole a de plus en plus
mauvaise presse ces quatre les enfants
deviennent des cas les toutous les
années 2000 pizzas pâtes à pain est
polluée par les pesticides en
agriculture représentent des ventes
faramineuses au québec
des ventes qui ont augmenté de 30% de
1992 à 2016 pour atteindre trois
millions et demi de kg d'ingrédients
actifs vendus et c'est sans compter les
semences enrobées de pesticides il faut
utiliser le moins possible pour donner
confiance aux travailleurs puis aussi
consommateurs
le gouvernement provincial a voulu
donner un coup de barre l'an dernier il
annonçait son intention de réduire de 25
% n'ont pas le total des pesticides
utilisés mais plutôt les risques pour la
santé et l'environnement des pesticides
jugés les plus nocifs
donc on s'est dit on va on va inciter
les gens finalement à travailler pour y
arriver le gouvernement offre donc un
soutien technique et financier aux
horticulteurs et producteur de céréales
qui participent à un projet pilote de
trois ans l'objectif réduire les risques
des pesticides à la faire quelques
emplettes et producteur de céréales en
mode conventionnel les grandes cultures
reçoivent de fortes doses de produits
phytosanitaires
il nous fait visiter un bâtiment tout
neuf où il entrepose ses pesticides
autre passion la pharmacie 80 pharmacies
on n'est pas obligé de tout parce que
s'établir polka pl était devenu au fil
du temps un adepte de ce qu'on appelle
l'agriculture raisonnée une agriculture
plus respectueuse de l'environnement
il fait des efforts soutenus pour
réduire la quantité de pesticides
utilisés à la ferme
il participe au projet pilote ça a
changé au niveau de la sécurité mais
aussi au niveau de notre conscience nous
autres comme agriculteur moi même comme
agriculteur j j'ai été longtemps dans
les options si je trouve pas plus de ce
que j'utilise à pau le producteur michel
lauzon a accepté lui aussi de participer
au projet pilote
ils cultivent des petits fruits du maïs
et des pommes un fruit très exposés aux
pesticides ce qu'ont été volée qui passe
quand la personne qui est à nous et des
effets à long terme de ces produits ne
pour fixer la hauteur de montgeron avec
son agronome paul capelette à élaborer
un plan match détaillé par exemple il
tente d'éliminer l'atrazine un herbicide
qui représente le risque le plus élevé
pour l'environnement et la santé
son utilisation nécessite maintenant une
prescription agronomique dans cette
parcelle de maïs l'atrazine a été
appliquée uniquement sur une petite
bande témoins
tout le reste est traitée avec un
mélange d'herbicides moins nocif la
pression de mauvaises herbes et
semblable des deux côtés mais on va voir
au fur et à mesure que la saison va
avancer parce l'atrazine sait comment un
produit très résiduel fois qu'on va voir
notre contrôle y est bon jusqu'à la fin
de l'été
michel lauzon lui cultive du maïs sucré
sans atrazine pour la première fois
cette année la canicule a frappé en juin
et les mauvaises herbes prolifèrent d'un
champ les herbicides de remplacement
sont moins efficaces
le producteur anticipe une baisse de
rendement de 15%
donc ça des effets sur le rendement que
vous avez oui je voudrais la main puis
la qualité des épis ou si des fois des
les écussons possible parce que iliad il
ya quelque chose qui obstruaient la
luminosité du feuillage de lippi fait
que cette fois les pieds
le feuillage peut être un peu plus bas
au monde alors ce fait que ça fait un
peu moins belle qualité de produit dans
ce champ de maïs poil capelette à couper
de moitié les arrosages contre les
mauvaises herbes et réaliser des
économies substantielles
il utilise une technique de précision et
pulvérise l'herbicide uniquement à la
base des plans
est ce qu'on doit en mettre autant
est-ce que moyen de de les remplacer de
faire par exemple au niveau des objets
de ce qu'on pourrait faire plus de
contrôles mécanique ça a été délaissé
avec est avec les années
paul capelette a justement prévu faire
du désherbage mécanique dans quelques
jours pour éliminer les graminées qui
nuisent à la croissance du maïs les
couteaux de saclas avons travaillé
vraiment centre du rhin vote auteurs
détruit ces petites mauvaises herbes
l'eau ça en produits
il faut en profiter pour mettre ni
fertiliser puis sommet mot couvert
végétal en même temps fac dans un même
pensé à l'opérateur va falloir être aux
opérations en dehors dans le même
passage diriez gady signé un enclos
quand on le voit là avec sa petite
bedaine
j'en le pile dessus le marais
les insectes ce sont les grands ennemis
de la pomme dans ses vergers michel
lauzon utilisent de plus en plus
d'outils destinés à la production
biologique comme ces diffuseurs de
phéromones sexuelles fixé dans la partie
supérieure des arbres il diminue les
populations de carpocapse un insecte
ravageur le verger devient saturé de
phéromones et les mâles confus ne
parviennent pas à s'accoupler avec des
femelles puis ça fonctionne assez bien
parce que on a l'impression pour faire
jusqu'à quatre traitements control list
un secteur qui aujourd'hui avec les
diffuseurs cac s'est bien fait puisqu'il
fait année après année on est bons
contrôles on peut arriver à éliminer
complètement le traitement insecticide
compte un secteur des pièges delta qui
diffuse des phéromones permet aussi de
capturer les mâles et de monitorer les
populations d'insectes
ça permet à l'agronome de savoir quand à
les observer les dommages sur les fruits
et de traiter si la situation l'exigé ce
que ça nous permet de mieux cibler le
traitement donc le moment à laquelle
auquel on veut traiter
dépendamment si on veut traiter les eaux
où les larmes c'est pas le même timing
puis en même temps ça nous permet
il y en a plusieurs dans le verger donc
ça nous permet de localiser les
traitements c'est cela le t'intégrer cdu
tant pis pour ceux qu'on finance des
services conseils dans le cadre de ce
projet le parce qu'on est conscient que
pour changer des pratiques ça demande un
bon suivi des champs ça me manque du
dépistage
ça demande de la réflexion ça demande du
temps pour apprendre à bien bien qu'on
ait les ravageurs qui détermine est la
bonne
la bonne méthode de look ce chant
l'homme ce cas plaide c'est une première
pour vous c'est la première fois qu'on
va sommer pour la première fois en 38
ans cole kaplitt fait des essais avec du
maïs biologique qui nie enrobé d'aucun
insecticide fongicide un maïs sans ogm
c'est prometteur moi là je vois pas bien
grosse frayeur sur l'assemblée ti cats
on les regarde comme soit propre
c'est lui que ce même que semaine
longueur d'avancé celui des traités
fixera coup d'arrêt
le système racinaire le feuillage la
vigueur et la densité des plans m'ont
traité sont pratiquement identiques aux
plans traité de la parcelle témoin la
lutte aux mauvaises herbes devra
cependant être adaptée comment vous
passez vous allez gérer les mauvaises
herbes de 0,9 à l'ancienne avec nos
retourne d'obtenir notre briques comme
vous avez vu tantôt sur l'ordinateur p ô
honte à l'esprit des herbicides qui
folie maïs qu'on appelle conventionnel
ça existe un masque pour guider les
producteurs agricoles un indicateur de
risque des pesticides a été mise au
point
ce guide classe les pesticides en
fonction de leur impact sur la santé et
l'environnement
et il propose des solutions de
remplacement soient les produits vont
retrouver formulé comme un mélange de
plein d'éléments puis pour le faire un
gros travail à défaire cette formule
l'eau pour peut-être aller enlever la
partie qui plus dangereux de kilos sur
l'échelle puis rafa sont mes hanches
sans cet élément le étonnamment le
glyphosate herbicide le plus vendu au
québec n'est pas ciblé par le programme
étant considérée à moindre risque à
saint joseph du lac les champs de
fraises de michel lauzon font l'objet
d'une étroite surveillance en début de
saison alors vous venez faire
l'opération dépistage exactement vous
allez chercher aujourd'hui mais en fait
on fait dépistage deux fois par semaine
puis ont chanté piste majoritairement
les insectes les carences les maladies
anto nomme punaise terne pucerons tetra
nique les insectes ravageurs peuvent
faire d'énormes dégâts dans les
fraisiers à une étape cruciale
on s'est vraiment moment où est ce que
les insectes sont les plus la population
est plus élevé les plus dommageables au
niveau des sauts économique puis les
traitements sont ciblés au bon moment
donc je savais mais comme nation passer
des titres annick des finances
on avait un peu plus de la population
d'insectes est importante et risque
encore d'augmenter car on prévoit du
temps chaud dans les jours à venir
un traitement phytosanitaire s'impose
comme ceux qui se recommandent un
produit qui patronat c'est fou les
abeilles parce que on est en fait raison
que l'on contrôle de fait de dommages
puis surtout dans les gens ont beaucoup
d'instinct que guide de pesticides à la
main michel lauzon ils sont à grenoble
détermine quel sera le pesticide le plus
approprié
ce serait intéressant celui ci on a des
risques un petit peu moins élevé le
niveau environnemental
mais ce n'est pas toujours simple de
cesser d'utiliser les pesticides les
plus nocifs paul capelette souhaite
éliminer complètement les semences de
maïs enrobé de néonicotinoïdes malgré
des demandes répétées à son fournisseur
ils n'arrivent pas à obtenir son hybride
de metz le plus performant en version
non traités enfin que ça fait deux trois
ans facile qu'on demande accompagnée de
six cachets de clients je peux pas avoir
de stand by et slow pas de traitement
jusqu'à d'aplomb certains m'ont dit on
en a parlé au représente un coût mais à
date ce n'est pas notre politique que
c'est un peu plate on dit aux gars de la
compagnie et je le veux je ne veux pas
de traitement sinon je me trouvais joie
de rokhaya dans les vergers de michel
lauzon le contrôle des insectes
ravageurs a été efficace pendant l'été
mais il a tout de même dû composer avec
les acariens et la tordeuse abandonnique
fonds était aussi capable d'accepter un
peu défaut celui flux et puis ce soit
des difficultés des des tâches ou
d'aider des piqûres d'insectes des
imperfections
en bout de ligne le producteur a vu ses
coûts d'application de pesticides baissé
mais les nouvelles façons de faire
demande du temps et une surveillance
constante
avez vous trouvé ce plus difficile à
gérer ça fait partie de la nouvelle
technologie de production agricole il
timing d'arrosage mais
c'est plus précis fixé cinq jours par
semaine puis ces 24 heures par jour
ce que c'est plus stressant pour lui que
ça des gta 20 faut sortir de sa zone de
confort et amorcer des changements que
c'est la théorie des petits pots paul
complète est satisfait il s'est beaucoup
creuser la tête et atteint ses objectifs
il ne manque pas d'idées pour améliorer
encore son bilan l'an prochain j'évolue
chiot cette année je m'envole au l'année
prochaine c'est tout en en approche -
rappel soit constructif
on ferait et modèle d'agriculture qui
est respectueux de tout ce qui nous
entoure
convoité asseyez des terrains un modèle
à notre façon au travail est un peu plus
forme un peu plus d'énergie mais c'est
ce qui nous passionne day tels faits
[Musique]